we have an extremely wide shot from
behind the bridge will also have a shot
from here it kind of tracks with bond
looking back towards the bridge one of
the real special things about working on
on the bond films is finding just the
right location for what the script is
calling for and you find a lot of time
in pre-production travelling from one
location to the next and trying to find
the ideal spot to shoot the scenes on
this film in particular we've got just
some really exciting places that were
shooting we have Shanghai which is a
really special city it's a really exotic
bond location and such a great skyline
we're here in Shanghai and the scene
that we're shooting is the arrival of
the trees and bond and play go from the
airport to where all the high-rises are
James Bond is tailing another character
which involves some cars on the highway
we're here behind me that's called the
Yan'an highway to major arterial road in
center and it has this got an unusual
blue lights it's an amazing city to see
at night I mean all the high-rises have
neon lights and advertising it I mean
it's amazing to the lens I haven't seen
anything like it
you